I've always been good with Bulls better
than I am with people so I sold my house
cashed out my 401k and I built this
place the bulltopia 250
000 square miles of nothing but
everything Bulls love cotton candy
Billiards aluminum foil sculptures old
fax machines and me they're Messiah I
got over 75 million Bulls living their
dream lives in the bulltopia and now
you're telling me a greedy corporate
real estate company has hired a hit
squad of the world's toughest Commandos
to kill me so they can bulldoze the
bulltopia and build a new laser tag
arena
good job boner
oh man I've been ready to die for the
bulltopia since the day I was born but
now I'm ready to kill for it